even though the iPhone 15 Pro is coming
in four short months we're already
seeing multiple leaks and rumors for the
iPhone 16 Pro so in this video I'm gonna
give you six good reasons why you should
upgrade to the 15 pro this year instead
of waiting so let's get right into the
first reason which is the redesign Apple
usually makes drastic changes to its
iPhone design every three years it
happened in 2014 with the rounded Edge
iPhone 6 2017 with the all-screen iPhone
10 2020 with the squared off iPhone 12
and it's happening again with the new
iPhone 15 lineup however this time it's
a bit more of a subtle change but it's
gonna work wonders for those who love
using their iPhone's caseless instead of
having a flat slab with squared off
Corners like we have on the current 14
lineup the new 15 models will introduce
a slide curve into all of the edges and
when I say slides I mean it as you can
see right here the old curved iPhone 6
design was was rounded all the way
through making it impossible for it to
stand up on a table that's what made the
iPhone 12 design really cool especially
for shooting b-roll videos on this
channel but the new 15 Pro will have
both it'll still be able to stand
upright due to the sides being flat but
just the outermost edges will be curved
to meet the glass panels on the front
and the back which is actually a bigger
deal than you think why well because
it'll no longer feel like the sharp edge
of your iPhone is digging into your palm
like we have right now it'll feel nice
smooth and pleasant to hold in the hand
being a more solid fit instead of
feeling intrusive on top of that it may
even give it the effect of looking just
a tad bit Slimmer because of how the
light reflects on the curved edges
similar to the effect of previous
MacBook designs which looked and felt
super thin but in reality they were
thicker than the new redesigned models
at the thickest point the iPhone 15
items should have the same effect
feeling just as thin as before even
though it'll actually get thicker this
year now another part of the redesign is
the super thin 1.5 millimeter bezels
which are only made possible because of
the curved Edge redesign merging the new
2.5 D glass into the frame similar to
how it's done on the Apple watch now on
to the second good reason you may have
not known this but when Apple introduced
the lightning port in 2012 they actually
said this this connector is a modern
connector for the next decade yes he
literally just said for the next decade
which means that 2023 should be the
first year not using lightning and yes
it will be we just got confirmation from
a variety of sources that the entire
iPhone 15 lineup will be getting a USBC
port instead of lightning and by far the
best source was unknown's 21 who
literally gave us a real photo of the
bottom of the 15 Pro making it even
better various 3D artists have created
renders showing how the entire iPhone
will look complete with the USBC port
and I've got to say the design looks
super good like in these renders from
Ian zelbo we also got leaks and rumors
from sources like shrimp Apple Pro and
Ming chikuo discussing how apple is
planning to keep their mfi program
around for their USBC accessories maybe
even forcing users to buy Apple's USBC
cables if they want the faster transfer
and charging speeds but even better we
got confirmation from analyst941 on
Twitter that the iPhone 15 Pro Models
are actually getting Thunderbolt ports
instead of just simple USBC which means
insanely fast transfer speeds he even
mentioned that apple is working on
unique software in iOS 17 that'll only
be unlocked when the iPhone 15 lineup is
released allowing special camera
features like using external monitors to
view what you're recording and real time
on the Pro Models and of course perhaps
the biggest benefit will be the ability
to use the same USBC cable for your
iPhone your iPad and all of your other
USBC devices so that is why upgrading to
the iPhone 15 is excellent timing since
I don't expect the port to change until
at least 2026 or later when Apple goes
completely poreless and relies on
wireless macsafe for data and charging
now on to the third good reason for the
first time in six years apple is
introducing a brand new metal to their
iPhone titanium and yes unknowns 21 has
confirmed that titanium will be at least
one of the available finishes on the
iPhone 15 pro and pro Max models it
looks even better in some of the renders
out there especially the ones from Ian
zelbo showing off that new brushed
titanium look and various finishes
including the new deep red but on top
top of that there are actually some
useful benefits to the new titanium
finish that you might not be thinking
about the first one is the fact that
titanium is stronger and more durable
than stainless steel and aluminum which
is why the new Apple watch Ultra comes
in titanium only but even better it's
actually lighter than stainless steel
just look at the weight difference
between the stainless and titanium
Series 7 Apple watch models the titanium
is actually closer in weight to aluminum
than stainless even though it's the
strongest of the three so for those who
don't really like iPhone Pro Models
because of the extra weight the 15 Pro
titanium will actually be quite nice for
you and now for the second reason the
new brushed titanium finish should do a
lot better in terms of fingerprint
resistance whereas the stainless steel
models are covered with fingerprints and
potential Grime almost right away the
new titanium likely won't have that
problem at all which is great now if
before we get into reason number four
I've gotta give a shout out to our
partner case who for their magic stand
case which is the most versatile case
I've ever used due to the fact that it
has a completely flush Max afring on a
hinge so you can use it as a stand for
things like watching videos or taking
photos at a variety of different angles
and the case itself is super rugged and
high quality as well and now casu is
offering a new payment method so you can
shop now and pay overtime with clarna so
check out the discount info and Link
down in the description below now
getting into the fourth reason we have
the action button yes the mute switch
that has been around since the original
iPhone is finally getting replaced with
something much more useful at least on
the 15 Pro Models because the regular
15s aren't getting it and that's why
I've been trying to tell you guys to buy
the Pro Models if you're considering an
upgrade to the new 15 lineup not only
that but it's fully programmable so you
can set it to do various functions as
well as open apps and control specific
features which will make it even more
useful apparently it'll also be able to
detect pressure so a quick press can do
one function a double press can probably
do another and a long press can do
something else so it's going to have a
ton of functionality I personally can
imagine myself using the button to
quickly open the camera app and take a
photo instead of having to wake the
display and swipe over to the camera or
I can set it to pause or play music or
when I'm bored I'll be able to long
press to toggle between mute modes to
feel the taptic engine now for reason
number five we have the a17 bionic chip
which is confirmed to be built on tsmc's
three nanometer process being the first
three nanometer chip in the world which
will lead to massive performance gains
as we've seen from leaks by Tech Reeve
on Twitter not only that but the new
three nanometer chip should greatly help
battery real life by being up to 35
percent more efficient than before and
then when you combine that with other
efficiency changes like a more efficient
display the new iPhone 15 Pro should get
a big boost in battery life and that
alone can make some people upgrade and
keep in mind that the iPhone 16 Pro
won't see as big of a jump because it'll
be using three nanometer chips again
potentially with a tuned second gen
process but it won't be anything like
going from five to three as we're
getting this year so upgrading to the 15
Pro is a great choice and finally we
have reason number six which is actually
an upgrade to my number one favorite
iPhone feature ever which is Max safe
yes I use this everywhere including in
my car at my house using my charging
stand and at the office as well with
this crazy high quality Grove made
charging stand well apparently with this
year's iPhone 15 Pro Apple will be
improving the max safe Wireless charging
speed up to 20 watts instead of the
current 15 which is a very nice 33 speed
boost which will surely help people feel
better about choosing to charge
wirelessly so there you have it those
are six very good reasons to upgrade to
the 15 pro this year instead of waiting
for the 16 Pro since all of these
features are nice upgrades and they
shouldn't really change that much next
year so the perfect time to upgrade will
be in
2023. now if you disagree with me let me
know down in the comment section below
but if you enjoyed the video click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]
all right